and
homosexuality in professional football
it's a topic many would prefer to ignore
but German musician Marcus V Bush has
made it the focus of a new Solomon
hopefully a number of professionals will
join together and say we're gay
hopefully they'll come a time when the
climate is better than today and they'll
be sick of leading double lives you can
do this for them to do believe me my
Fuhrer probability alone dictates that a
certain percentage of professional
footballers must be gay but homophobia
unfortunately remains part of everyday
footballing reality z bush is a fan of
the left-wing hamburg club Zonk poly his
song this day will come tells the story
of a young pro footballer who's gay but
doesn't dare come out the video for the
song is intended to be provocative it's
already attracted more than 3/4 of a
million hits on YouTube if you look at
other famous people who've come out
people like Ricky Martin hito Vesta Vela
Elton John rugby player Gareth Thomas or
American football player Michael Sam
they all said the day I came out was the
day my life began but no active
professional in Germany has ever come
out as gay and Cummings out remain a
rarity in the international game as well
homophobia among fans is probably one
reason for them
you wouldn't believe how often I read
when I was doing my research that there
are absolutely no homosexual football
players because it's allegedly not their
kind of sport an absolutely ridiculous
idea
homophone for it your Naya don't made a
fool for cyber aside to state hyemi's
time guys that look back
not even succeed
I've never heard a single sentence that
doesn't reflect how stupid homophobia is
there's no sentence that starts I'm a
homophobe because without the rest being
pure idiocy the protagonist and be
Bush's song tries to cover up his
homosexuality by living a lie I have
four or five sources who told me that
homosexual players are given fake wives
and girlfriends I mean but the women are
just for show the video features fans of
first and second division clubs
including zonked poly minds
FC Bayern Schalke Nuremberg and Bremen
taking a stand against homophobia but
not all supporters proved so tolerant
we contacted Borussia Dortmund and
Maidan appointments we had everything
set up the camera the hotel and then we
got a call telling us that it was no use
not enough people intended to show up I
was disappointed of course Dortmund is a
huge club so I couldn't imagine there
would be a problem getting a couple of
hundred people together the fan
representatives and a lot of the
supporters regret not taking part buying
a part of it as our shell cast and
they're not by an acerbic psycho stuff
as easily survived standing up against
homophobia the idea is catching on at
teams around the world
English club Arsenal produced a humorous
video entitled the changing room to
promote tolerance
I can't change my height I can't change
that look like a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle icon chamber I'm gorgeous but
together we can change the game players
are lacing up to kick homophobia out of
football
use hashtag rainbow laces to get
involved and show your support cowabunga
the club leading the way in Germany is
tennis Borussia Berlin from the sixth
division its fans have taken a stand
against homosexuality since the 1990s
here homosexuals are accepted as part of
normal everyday reality the day to come
from be bushes song has already arrived
at tennis Borussia for us it's not an
issue it's a matter of course and we'd
like to spread that message and to talk
about the topics teammates especially
Tenace ferocious fans were of course
more than willing to participate in be
Bush's video but what about the players
as a rematch oft acknowledge them to
assure the team is aware of the fans
banners and choreography of course but
it's not much of a topic in the dressing
room we just concentrate on football
we're aware of it but it's not something
we talk about much and the coaching
staff they're completely behind the idea
of tolerance and they've even got a few
ideas for how football could become even
more tolerant it would be a start if a
couple of functionaries came that might
get people into the mindset okay let's
come out let's take the first Germany's
Football Association the DFB has
launched publicity campaigns against
homophobia in the past but many people
say it needs to do more to change the
culture surrounding the game perhaps the
DFB should educate people maybe it
should say let's travel the country from
the 1st to the 4th division and openly
discuss the topic or in the team's
themselves so that players are no longer
afraid if there are players who are
homosexual they should be able to come
out in the teams and comps the missus
talk to him that in their munch often
for his own flesh Odin
to be my tennis Borussia are doing the
same thing that some poly do so well the
fans take care of their end and ensure
there's a climate in which it makes no
difference if someone's homosexual
tennis Borussia are pioneers but so is
st. Pauli fans of these two clubs would
have no problem supporting openly
homosexual players and Marcus V Bush is
sure that the day will come when an
active player will say I'm gay but not
right now this are you gay no good would
you come out if you were a gay player
not in the current climate
someday that climate will change
someday someone will step forward
you